well there's no doubt that regular
cancer screenings can save your life and
it may be easier to treat in a lot of
cases it is
when it's detected early hector mejia is
live this morning talking with doctors
about
colorectal cancer awareness and has some
really important information we could
all use hi hector good morning
hey there alex good morning we are at
comprehensive cancer centers by eastern
and twain at their central valley
location just
getting a behind the scenes look at what
it takes to do some research too so
we're also talking about the topic and
we're also getting
a live look at some of the work that's
happening here so this is where some of
the blood samples
are collected tested and some are frozen
for research and believe it or not a lot
of
clinical trials are happening here in
our own valley
joining us live we have dr fadi brayte
medical oncologist here
to talk to us all right so what's the
main message you want folks to get at
home as we talked about colorectal
cancer awareness month good morning sir
good morning colon cancer
it's still you know the second deadliest
cancer in man
it's one of the common cancer we
recognize a thousand people would die
will die a week from colon cancer
although four out of five new colon
cancer are early
stage cancer which are treated with
surgery chemotherapy
radiation twenty percent of one and five
are already presenting
in late stage disease and uh it's also
interesting to know
because you know during the pandemic a
lot of people postponed getting screened
so doctors all across the country are
expecting a surge
in in in rates absolutely elective
surgeries and procedures colonoscopy
being elected during the pandemic
has been placed on hold for many
patients because of shortages of
materials
and to avoid hospital crowding this has
really put pressure and a backlog on
cases
to undergo screening you know there are
different modalities colonoscopy being
a preferred one from my by for myself
because it allows you to
removal of pre-cancerous lesions
doctor for those watching at home who
you know may be curious well i don't
know what to look out for
what are some of those warning signs or
symptoms to
pay attention to first if you're 45 or
older
no symptoms needed you qualify for
screening talk to your primary care
doctor
otherwise even if you're younger and i
insist if you're younger
any blood in this tool any change in
your bowel habits constipation diarrhea
that is lasting more than two weeks that
is a warning anemia if otherwise not
explained and not worked up
could be the early signs of cancer and
hopefully you don't wait to
start experiencing unexplained weight
loss
is of concern and of course abdominal
pains
i'm not saying every abdominal pain is a
sign of cancer
is a signal as well doctor thank you for
your time and for giving us a behind the
scenes look here
before patients even come in this
morning so
there you have it you know make sure
your loved ones know about it you know
encourage
them to get screened i'm actually going
to give my dad a call ask him if he
got screened uh anytime recently you
know make sure everyone is healthy
so we can all have a you know long life
and we can all you know enjoy our own
family time with each other
for now reporting live hector mejia 8
news now back to you guys